well it's amazing isn't it I mean the
extraordinary thing is actually to be
turned into a bit of it yourself
because I now appear in this as a
hologram I mean I'm not there at all
they can make me do all sorts of funny
things so that's a bit weird I must say
but they haven't done the tricks that I
do with with the objects when I you pick
an object I encourage you was as taking
part in this big 3d experience to look
at the thing and sometimes to enlarge it
and I don't think anybody's done that to
me yet
something that suddenly I become a sort
of a great job
so beautiful what I really liked about
it was the fact that you could pick
items up and enlarge them and have a
look and you talked us through it it's a
very unique position you're telling a
story and interacting with people in a
different way how have you found it
enhanced your storytelling well I think
when you go to a museum you see all
these fabulous objects some of them the
only one of their kind in the world and
you do yearn to break through the glass
and pick it up and turn it around and
have a look at it
and to be invited to do that making all
the rows which seems to break all the
rules and to look at where a dragonfly
for example when it's all very well to
see you see it in them on a board pinned
to a board with a pin through it and
that's the museum exhibit and perhaps
I'm doing him down a bit I don't always
have pins in them but but nonetheless
it's static and of course John aren't
static they were and they fly in the
most amazing way and you want yarns we
have look at the back of it that you
can't see because it's in that
particular position in the museum and
then to be able to be invited to say
well they are using your zappers we put
it down on the table now you can pick it
up you can turn it around you can have a
closer look at the eye and then you can
actually make the eye go big there so
you can actually see the structure of
the eye and when at the end of it you
say well they won't let you see it would
you like to get it to move press the
magic button and there's a magic moment
and the butterfly and the dragonfly
roars it rings everywhere and it's off
and and it flies around you I mean just
absolutely fabulous magical it feels
like in the last few years you've gone
from being known as an explorer to a
conservationist has this been a
conscious shift or is this been
something that you found yourself having
to do because of what you've seen when
you've been traveling the globe over the
last 50 years 60 years the number of
people on the earth has tripled three
times as many as the world when I first
started making television programs and
they all want houses
like you and me they all want roads to
drive on they want places their schools
and so on and where does that come from
by and large it comes from the natural
world so by and large we are eating up
the natural world as it were for our own
purposes
well that's self-destruction actually
and if you damage their natural world in
the end you damage yourself and the
human race will regret you're bringing
the issues into people's front rooms and
it does seem that there is a public
swell of support for preserving the
oceans here at Sky we have sky ocean
rescue and the amount of plastic that's
going into the sea a lot of people are
conscious of what they do now and are
changing their habits as a result how
green are you at home do you use a
reusable coffee cup do you use your
reusable bags well I can tell you in the
last I've changed from taking bottles of
water in passing bottles and using tap
water which you put through a purifier
and then putting it into a glass bottle
which is a regular so we only use one
bottle from that point of view but but
there is so much simple as simple things
that we can do which for which there is
sometimes no reason at all it seems to
me do you think plastic packaging should
be bound well then in some place I mean
it's absurd to suggest that we can do
totally without plastic but there are
certainly many many areas where we use
plastic without a thought six stores for
example do you think they should be
better the the I remember well sure as a
schoolboy being told by my chemistry
master who came in today said boys said
we you're going to live in a new age you
cannot open the plastic age where we're
going to take all this stuff and what is
so wonderful about it is that is
indestructible
it doesn't wear out it's there and Nero
not one of us said what hammers how do
you get rid of it well you know when you
got too much extraordin that and nobody
seemed to have thought of that back
there in the 30s well they're thinking
about it now and the government has set
itself a target of cut
our plastic waste by 2042 is the
government grasping the seriousness of
the situation is that an urgent enough
target by then will it be too late in
your irreversible
we have to go as fast as we can and and
so you faced a few of the government
you're faced with though do you go as
fast as you would wish or do you keep
the target something which is actually
reachable I mean the tumbler if you say
you've got to do a whole area of life
and get rid of it altogether people
couldn't subdue couldn't exist without
passing in various forms of one sort or
another
so you think 2042 is realistic I think I
think I hope so but but but and if it's
not we can do that I mean if we as a
public managed to be able to get rid of
this stuff more than the government's
talking that's fine we can we can
improve on that we can we can go that
far is there a tipping point do you
think are we going to reach a certain
point where the damage is irreparable if
you give nature a chance it recovers and
we've demonstrated that with Wales you
know Wales were on the verge of
extinction 50 years ago they really were
and it was a it was a seafaring nations
of the world that got together and say
we will stop doing it if the world can
get together and stop doing it there
will be a huge improvement and I'm
optimistic I think that there's a
stronger movement in this country and
indeed worldwide I was stronger
recognition of how important the natural
world is done that has ever been in my
lifetime certainly he made a very
passionate speech last year at the UN
about climate change we have president
Trump potentially visiting the UK later
this summer who is a climate change
denier if he were to sit down with him
when he came on a visit how would you
convince him to see your way of the
world well you can produce lots and lots
of pictures and you can produce lots and
lots of facts but I have the feeling
that mr. Trump has made up his mind and
I don't think he's going to be
susceptible to that sort of argument
there are plenty of great propagandists
or great champions of the National
the United States who are close to Trump
and and give the chance of speaking his
own language people who in his own
country and so on but it seems that what
they say are falling on deaf ears it's
interesting do you think that we can
fight climate change without having
America on board I well the president is
election every four years and the
Chancellor even at maximum it's only
eight
so I Trump is not there forever and just
finally what's next for you you say
you'll never retire and you still want
to explore its space something you're
interested in are you going to compete
in the space race or the likes of
Richard Branson and you know musk no I
mean what I love about the world of
other living things and I know answers
to the problems on our planet elsewhere
the one around we have no evidence of
that and you've got to take years of
your life to go anywhere else even
getting to them I'd love to go to the
moon for a day for a day it's a long way
to go for a day looking forward to
seeing that program it's David aspera
thank you so much for talking to us
thank you